This repo hit 30,000 stars within 12 days\h
of going viral. It has 120 AI personas that\h\h
you can clone in just 10 seconds for marketing,\h
engineering, sales, design, QA, game development,\h\h
and special computing. I've tested it. Here is\h
the generic output and here is the output with\h\h
specialized persona loaded. Same model, same\h
question. And I saw significant improvement\h\h
in the response quality. In this video, we are\h
going to cover what really it is, how it works,\h\h
how to use it in claude code that turns them from\h
static prawn files into actual working sub aents\h\h
that run in parallel, keep their own context, and\h
even build memory across sessions. And that last\h\h
part is the most useful thing in the video. So\h
stay till the end. Agency agents is open source\h\h
collection of about 120 markdown files. This\h
number may increase going forward. And each file\h\h
is a structured AI persona. Now one important\h
clarification is that despite the name agency\h\h
agents, these are not AI agents in the way most\h
people think of that term. They do not use tools\h\h
on their own. They do not have persistent memory.\h
They do not make autonomous decisions. They are\h\h
structured system prompts. You can think of them\h
as detailed job descriptions for AI. But with the\h\h
right setup, you can turn them into actual working\h
sub-agents in claude code. We will get to that.\h\h
Let me show you what is actually inside one of\h
these files. Now this is marketing growth hacker\h\h
agent. At the top you have got YAML formatter\h
name, description, tools, color, emoji and w. Then\h\h
it has the identity layer. This agent has a name,\h
a personality. Then it has the core capabilities.\h\h
Then it has specialized skills, decision framework\h
and success metrics. It is a job description,\h\h
not a oneliner. But does it actually make a\h
difference? Let us test it. It's the same model\h\h
and same task. Now I'm going to ask help me create\h
a content marketing strategy for a B2B SAS product\h\h
that helps small teams manage projects. Our query\h
will remain the same but on the right hand side we\h\h
will also add the Asian personality. I'll copy\h
it from here and paste it over here. Now let's\h\h
run both of these and see how it goes. Now both of\h
these are complete. Let's open the file generated\h\h
by the query without any persona. Looks like there\h
is some issue loading this document. So let's ask\h\h
it to fix. All right, the issue is fixed. Now\h
let's download the file and open it. And here\h\h
is the doc. It has the executive summary,\h
ideal customer profile and buyer personas,\h\h
then content pillars and messaging framework,\h
channel strategy, then quarterly content road map,\h\h
KPIs and success metrics, team and budget and\h
competitive differentiation in content. So this is\h\h
a decent response. Now let's look at the response\h
generated by our second query where we used the\h\h
agent persona. Let's download the file and open\h
it. Again it contains the executive summary,\h\h
ideal customer profile, content pillars and\h
topics. But I think this is more detailed. It\h\h
has multiple pillars, SEO and keyword strategy.\h
It has defined it in multiple tiers and then\h\h
it has 12 month content calendar framework,\h
distribution and channel strategy, lead generation\h\h
and conversion optimization. then metrics,\h
KPIs and reporting, then growth experiments,\h\h
then recommended budget allocation and 30 60 90day\h
action plan. As you can see, this is much more\h\h
detailed and the quality of the doc has improved\h
significantly from our previous one. Let's drop\h\h
both of these files over here and we'll ask\h
claude itself to evaluate both of these and tell\h\h
us which is better and why. And here we go. So,\h
it says doc with Asian personite wins by roughly\h\h
68% versus 32%. And that is huge. Agent persona\h
version is significantly better because of depth\h\h
and actionability. Content calendar is actually\h
usable. Email nurture is fully built out. Keyword\h\h
strategy is 3x more specific. Growth experiments\h
and PLG loops and repurposing framework. And this\h\h
is the weighted scorecard. We got 8.65 versus\h
6.05 which is around 60 to 70% increase in the\h\h
quality. Now setting this up is really easy. You\h
need to come to this GitHub repo. Click on code.\h\h
You can either download the zip directly and\h
start using the files or you can clone it. But\h\h
if you plan to make changes to those files and\h
then push them back then I would suggest you\h\h
fork this project then create fork. Once this is\h
done you will start seeing it in your space. Then\h\h
you can go to code copy this command then open\h
visual studio and make sure you have claude code\h\h
extension installed. Then click on these three\h
dots click on terminal new terminal. And here you\h\h
can run git clone and paste the URL. Make sure you\h
have git installed on your computer. And within\h\h
5 seconds you will have all of your agency agents\h
in your project. Next let's open claude code. And\h\h
now we need to perform a really important step\h
which is transforming these agent files into\h\h
sub aents that can be used by claude code. And to\h
do that we need to scroll down copy this command\h\h
from here. Let's ask claude to execute it. And\h
it is done with a setup. It has set up the Asian\h\h
directories at this path. Let's copy this path\h
and to confirm let's cd into this directory in\h\h
the terminal. Now let's run ls command and it will\h
give us the list of all the directories and files\h\h
present at this path and as you can see it has\h
copied everything. Similarly you can set it up\h\h
for all of these tools. You just need to run the\h
corresponding command. All right. So now how do we\h\h
use these prompts for our claude code agent? And\h
it's really simple. We can either give the name\h\h
of our agent persona over here and ask it to use\h
that agent or we can even tag that particular MD\h\h
file and it will pick it up from there. So this\h
is the part I said was the most useful. Let's\h\h
say you are building a landing page. Instead of\h
doing everything sequentially, you tell Claude\h\h
research the UX layout, content strategy and SEO\h
requirements in parallel using separate sub-agents
and claude will launch three sub agents\h
simultaneously and look at these todos.\h\h
First one is research UX layout requirements via\h
UX architect sub agent. Second is research content\h\h
strategy via content creator sub agent and third\h
one is research SEO via SEO specialist sub agent\h\h
and it has launched all of these three sub agents\h
in parallel. All the three sub agents are now\h\h
done. It has created these documents that contains\h
a detailed content strategy and SEO strategy. This\h\h
is the multi- agent orchestration and instead\h
of you manually switching between personas,\h\h
Claude is the orchestrator. It routes tasks to\h
the right specialist automatically. Now let's\h\h
talk about the real long-term value. You can pick\h
an agent that is close to what you need. Let's say\h\h
LinkedIn content creator. And now you can very\h
easily customize it as per your requirement.\h\h
You can change the vibe colors and you can add\h
your tools that this agent will have access to.\h\h
You can set your own model for this sub agent by\h
adding model colon your model name. And you can\h\h
even give a persistent memory directory to this\h
sub agent by adding memory colon project. This\h\h
gives the agent a persistent memory directory that\h
survives across conversations. So every time you\h\h
use it, it learns from your content creation\h
patterns, your terminology, your framing,\h\h
etc. It writes these to a memory file that\h
it reads at the start of the next session.\h\h
And once you do all of these things, what you\h
have is not some generic prompt file. Instead,\h\h
it is your custom sub agent which is tuned to your\h
specific use case and it gets smarter and smarter\h\h
every time you use it. Before you go all in, let\h
us talk about what is not perfect because I think\h\h
the honest picture is more useful than hype. First\h
one is we don't have any benchmarks yet. The MIT\h\h
study tells us that structured prompts should help\h
and our test shows a visible difference as well.\h\h
But nobody has done rigorous quantitative\h
testing of these specific personas against\h\h
alternatives. So these are not necessarily the\h
best system prompts that exist for these roles.\h\h
Second is quality varies. 120 agents from 50\h
plus contributors. Some are deeply researched\h\h
with specific frameworks, detailed workflows and\h
real deliverables. Others may be thinner. The\h\h
recently added divisions are newer and less battle\h
tested than the originals. So is it worth using?\h\h
Yes, if you do it right, but it would be a\h
better idea to treat it as a starting point,\h\h
not a magic solution. You can pick one\h
agent, test it, fork it, customize it,\h\h
build memory. That is how you go from a prompt\h
library to an actual AI workflow that gets\h\h
better over time. Tell me in the comments which\h
agent personas would be most useful for your\h\h
work right now. In the next video, we are going\h
deeper. I'll be picking agents from this repo\h\h
and use them to build real workflows. If that\h
sounds useful, subscribe so you don't miss it.